So what would be a piece of
information that if we knew it,
would make it relatively straightforward
to figure out what new state we were in?
>> Well if we knew what state we were
in before, since we have a transition
model we know which states
we are likely to be in next.
>> Yeah okay, let's just write that.
That's a that's a really good start.
So what we're saying is,
let's break things down by
the possible state that we started in.
And what we want to know and
we're going to weight things by,
what's the probability that
that's the state we started in?
Given B A Z.
Then given that, what's the probability
of the next state given that state?
So this is going to help us
break things down, successfully.
So let's see if we can do that.
So what do we know about
the probability of being in a state,
given a belief state that we took
an action and we made some observation?
So I think the thing to point out here
is that the observation that we saw
is generated by the state
that we ended up in.
And so we're actually trying to figure
out what state we are in, basing
observation we got, when, in fact,
the generative model goes the other way.
So this is a prime situation
to try to use Bayes' Rule.
>> Prime.
>> [LAUGH] It's an s prime situation for
using Bayes' Rule.
So that gives us the probability of
making an observation, given the state
that we're in, or that we arrived in s
prime and carrying over the a and the s.
And the probability that that's
the state we ended in, given a and
s, divided by the normalization factor.
The probability of the observation,
given a and s.
>> Right.
>> All right.
So now we're getting really close
to quantities that we recognize.
In particular, the probability of an
observation given the state that we just
landed in is independent of the action
and the state that we just talked.
So this is going to be
the observation function.
This right here is the transition
function the probability of landing in
some state as prime given that we
were in state S and took action A.
And then this is just going to be
a normalization factor at the bottom.
>> Right.
>> So substituting those quantities in
and rewriting out this
normalization factors is basically
the numerator divided by the sum of
all the possible next eight s prime.
We get one component of the new police
state be prime if we apply the same idea
over all possible states as prime.
Then we get a probability distribution
over all the states that represents
the likelihood of being in those states
given that we In belief state b,
took action a, and made observation z.
>> So that's intuitively obvious,
even to the most casual observer.
But more importantly, it just uses
all the quantities we already had.
>> [LAUGH] It does, it seems like
sort of when a TV series is over and
they bring all the characters back for
one last show.
It's like we've got to B back,
and the O back, and the Z back.
Everybody is friends again.
>> And it spells bOT.
>> [LAUGH] And it spells bOT.
So my point is that these quantities
can be easily calculated from.
Or sorry, this quantity, this b prime
s prime can be easily calculated from
quantities that we have lying around
because we have the model, the POMDP.
And we know what the previous
belief state is and
we know what action we just took and
what observation we made.
And so all this can be updated.
And so we can keep track of
this notion of where we are.
This belief state notion
of the belief MDP.
>> I like it.
>> Cool.
All right so
this doesn't actually tell us how to
do decision making because all we
done actually it's we
turned a POMDP into an MDP.
That by the way has
an infinite number of states.
So we can you know we have a number of
algorithms that we can run like linear
programming or policy iteration or
value iteration.
And [LAUGH] they all at best grow
polynomial in the number of states.
So it's polynomial in infinity,
so infinity.
>> So it's a constant.
>> Yeah, no.
[LAUGH] It's bigger than any constant.
So this is problematic.
We can't just Take this MDP now that
we've defined it and just solve it using
our existing algorithms, we're going to
have to be a little bit more careful.
And so I want to step through
the algorithmic process for
how you can actually do that.
It's kind of nice I think.
>> Okay, I mean, I can't wait to see
how you make infinity finity, so
let's do it.